all right
welcome
to this talk about running Blazer in
production and the lessons learned
so some people love Blazer
and let's just face it some haven't
tried it yet
so how many of you have tried Blazer
before
almost everyone okay how many uh wants
to use Blazer
so how is that not more
so there are people that tried Blazer
that don't that don't want to use okay
so how many of you are a little bit
unsure about place right what what is
this stuff I don't know yeah a couple of
you okay awesome
my name is Jimmy angstrom I'm a
Microsoft MVP in um
developer Technologies I just switched
areas
and I've been we've been running Blaze
reproductions since well seven days
after it's release
I run a podcast called cold enough to
work together with my lovely wife
and we also do a stream on Twitch so if
you want to see us code Blazer stuff and
interview some awesome guests please
check that out we're actually building a
call for paper site right now with using
Blazer and Raven DB
I've written a book about Placer and I'm
currently writing a second edition
which will come out in March I think
around there and these are the only two
Blazer books
that has raccoons on the cover
it's important
okay we're here to talk about Blazer
let's um let's go back to 2017.
when Steve Sanderson had a web assembly
talk on uh at NDC Oslo
and he thought you know what
it would be kind of cool to show
something something like running.net
in the web browser wouldn't that be kind
of a cool demo
so when it takes the stage he has
working Visual Studio support
he has even the name Blazer which is not
a lot of names stick around for that
long so even the name Blazer and he had
running C sharp code inside of the
browser he took an open source project
of the.net runtime compiled that
webassembly and then ran the.net dlls
right there in the web browser that's
kind of cool
so why is Blazer awesome
well I saw a Reddit post
um that kind of embodied and and really
got that message across
it said
this feels like cheating
I feel like I'm getting away with
something
and it shouldn't be this easy to build
sites
how many feel the same
okay yeah a bunch of you
and I mean me included I'm not that
comfortable with writing JavaScript I I
don't like switching between JavaScript
and typescript
but the nice thing with blazer here is
that I don't have to
there's no extra framework I need to
download and I don't need any extra
skills like angular or react so for me
this like it's like the perfect solution
now I read somewhere that glazers for
developers that don't want to learn new
things and for me that is not the case I
love learning new things but I
to be fair I kind of tend to stay in the
C sharp stack
but there's a saying that Misfortune
never comes alone and for me that
Misfortune is npm webpack the typescript
JavaScript power angle you know all
these other technologies that I need to
be the best at to be able to do work
basically
so for me Blazers removing clutter
making me
focus on what I need to do
and well that's where Blazer comes in
I got a um
a friend request on Facebook
and since I'm out talking at conferences
like this I'm sure I probably met this
person
so he said so um
are you um
working with laser
um yeah yeah I am someone perhaps
talking saw my talk or some read my book
or whatever so I thought yeah yeah yeah
yeah yes I I I'm I'm working with bison
never going to be a thing
that's good to know I just invested my
half my life basically here so that's
good to know but but I asked him what
why do why do you think why isn't this
this is going why is this not going to
be a thing
well they said well it's never going to
be danger react
well kind of not the point
it's kind of more getting letting us as
C shop developers do interactive
websites with the knowledge we already
have without content context switching
and all of that I mean there can be more
than one Spa framework it's This Is Not
Highlander this is
technology right
and Blazer isn't really just another
framework it's part of.net
and s.net developers I'm assuming most
of you are dot-net Developers
yeah huh
there's no reason not to
think about Blazer try Blazer out
because it's a very mature technology at
this point
we're still kind of saying like Blazers
in Microsoft new technology for small
framework well it's three years old now
there's a lot of framework that doesn't
reach three years so it I don't know is
it still new
I am teach at a school
uh a um accelerating Excel
I've been trying to say that word for so
long and I never managed to say that
accelerated learning there we go too
much caffeine
so basically we have a someone that have
never seen a
code at all
they come in they they get get to be
become a developer in 12 weeks basically
I mean they're not senior developers but
they are developers in in the 12 weeks
so I asked them so um
would you like me to um to come in and
teach Blazer I would love to do that
and they're no no no no one is asking
about Blazer no we have we have people
asking for angle we have people asking
for a react they do teach asb.net of
course but no one is asking for Blazer
and that's kind of the point
they're asking for asp.net Blazers part
of asp.net it should be in there
but
Blazer has another problem
and that is we can run Blazer on so many
things we can run it on the server we
can run it in webassembly and now we can
run it in Blazer hybrid with docket Maui
and this leads into kind of naming and
naming problem because we're saying that
we're using Blazer but what part of
Blazer are we using
I'm contacted contacted a um podcast and
I said you know what I I would be happy
to be a guest on your podcast we can
talk about Blazer talk about all these
really cool Technologies
and the reply was well we just talked
about webassembly so when we don't want
another web assembly talk or or a guest
I'm like
but that's just one way of running
Blazer we can we can run it on so much
more but okay
so last year at the NDC London we
recorded a podcast with Steve Sanderson
and I I asked him
so what kind of Trends are you seeing
are you seeing the same because when I
talk to companies companies say that
well we're using Blazer server not a lot
of companies are investing web in
webassembly that I've talked to so I
asked him do you see the same Trends is
this happening with the people you talk
to as well
and he said yeah
most people or most companies are
running places server
now to be fair Blazer server was around
was around like a year before
webassembly I think so it has a little
bit of overhead start
and webassembly is growing really fast
so it's not really like saying like you
should invest in places where you should
invest in Blazer webassembly but
a lot of these talks
talks like this books blog posts within
they talk about very heavily about
webassembly like that's the only option
but it's not we also have Blazer server
so let's dive in and just figure out
where all of these different
Technologies comes in
so we have Blazer server let's start
with that
so we have the server and on the server
we have eraser components
then we have Blazer so Blazer is taking
whatever the the razor components it's
it's outputting
and put them into a rendered tree
okay so it knows what what what's going
on and what what kind of elements we
have so let's say that we have an H1 and
a button
because why not
and then we have the browser
and on the browser side we have Dom
we have a little bit of piece of
JavaScript
which is responsible to set up a signal
or connection to the server
so there are some downsides and we're
going to come back to that in a minute
so
the render tree knows what it actually
has sent over so it's just going to send
if in this case we don't have anything
in the Dom we're going to send over the
H1 the button and the JavaScript is then
going to take the Dom
awesome
so let's say that I click the button
that request or that that trigger will
go over the JavaScript all the signalr
up to the razor components it's going to
execute some kind of code
which is then going to update the Dom or
sorry the render Tree in this case it's
a very subtle change I change Blazer
rules to an S instead of a z
Blaise is then going to push only that
change over to the JavaScript and then
update it on this is not entirely true
because it actually I think it's three
requests happening it's it's one that
says the button click the
um the data back and then an
acknowledgment saying okay I got that
and it's not sending the actual H1 tag
and all of that but in in general it
sends the update to the server
so when it comes to webassembly we need
to understand how JavaScript works just
a little bit
so what happens is that we downloaded
JavaScript
we pause the JavaScript either from a
file or from inline
and then it's going to get compiled and
then the jit interpreter is going to run
the code
with webassembly we kind of bypass some
of those steps because the digit
interpreter can run webassembly right
there
so what Microsoft did was that they took
the mono runtime
compile that to.net or sorry to
webassembly to.net.wassem
and then that
webassembly code is running our dlls and
the framework dlls right there in the
web browser
so when I realized this I
I cannot it's one it's running the same
it's running the whole runtime inside
the browser that that felt a little bit
wrong to me
but then I realized that if you just say
it another way it's running the whole
run time inside of the browser
that is kind of cool
but what we also can do is we can with
Darkness six we got ahead of time
compilation so basically we can remove
the dlls and put everything and compile
everything to webassembly
now the downside is of course that the
webassembly file is going to be a lot
larger
but it's going to load and execute
things
super super fast really really fast
so back to the server This Is How They
place a server worked
webassembly
the only changing the the waiver hosting
things now everything lives inside of
the browser the dotnet.wassm is running
on razor components running Blazer
creating the render tree
we have still have the Dom but still
have a little piece of JavaScript but
instead of signalr we're getting
JavaScript interrupts because
as of now webassembly don't have access
direct access to the Dom so that's
what's happening
so it's
it's in how they're it's working just
where it's running that's differs
so what about Blazer hybrid well
so let's have webassembled as a starting
point
so four.net malware or Blazer hybrid we
now
we can now run inside of iOS Android Mac
OS windows and even Tyson
it's running inside of dotnet Maui we
have.net.net for iOS or net for Android
running our racer components this is the
same dlls that I'm we've been talking
about
till we've got Blazer we still have a
render free
we can combine native components
together with
with web or Dom elements
so here's where things get really cool
so with the same racer components the
same razor component Library
we can reach Blazer server a Blazer web
assembly through the web
using.net Maui we can reach iOS
Android
Mac OS
Tyson and windows
and using web View
we can even use win forms or WPF
so we can use all of these things
together with our Blazer libraries
it's kind of cool huh
I see people nodding
it's about what about this this is kind
of the the promise right no more
JavaScript
I would say this is a kind of a little
bit of a myth but
it depends on where you're coming from
so if you're coming from MVC and you're
coming from race pages
it might be a little bit more JavaScript
than you were used to
because especially in the beginning with
the darkness 5 for example there were
some things that we needed JavaScript to
do for one example is changing the page
title that they fixed at thank God
but there are some things we still need
JavaScript to access native resources
native
Bluetooth for example
so it's not entirely true that we we
never need to see JavaScript but the
Blazer Community is quite large
so chances are that someone has built it
what we need already
so we went into production seven days
after Blazer was General availability
and
we felt that there were some things that
were missing
so we've built our own grid component
which meant that we needed a little bit
of JavaScript in there
so I've written I I usually say that
when I started started working with
started working with blazer
I have never written as much JavaScript
as when I started working with replacer
so this is definitely not true for me
but it can be for many people
now the really cool thing is that
it's still possible to use JavaScript
so if you have your like you have your
favorite JavaScript framework you have
or components or something like that you
can still do that you can still do
JavaScript interrupts
now I would perhaps not recommend mixing
languages and but it is possible because
with dotnet 7 we got something called
Web components
and this works both ways
so this means that I can bring in
angular or react or actually it's it's a
complete another technology but web
components into JavaScript web
components I should say into our Blazer
project
as well as create Blazer components that
I can use in my JavaScript libraries so
if we're kind of porting something we're
moving towards hey
we might be moving towards angular or
react or we're moving towards Blazer we
can use all these Technologies together
again I'm not sure that I recommend it
but it is possible I would probably use
it in in like in a transition phase but
I kind of like that it's possible
so I did a video on Tick Tock and I said
is uh Blazer production ready and
basically said yes
and I got comments
so there was a guy that
had some really great feedback so he
said no it's not gonna be a thing it's
it's I'm gonna lose I think he used 70
percent of of all the things in angular
moving to Blazer and I'm like yeah is
that is that really good thing
um I have done very little with angular
I've definitely done almost a little bit
more in react but still I don't know
that space
so I was a little bit curious so what
are the things that you're missing what
are those 70 that
just goes away
so one of the things was angular
material
so I I try to look this up what is it
how does it work do we have it and yes
we do we have math Blazer and we have
mud Blazer so both of those
are I don't know if they're equivalent
but it's it's something in the same
lines
angular Flex there's an open source
project called flexor which works great
for Blazer
we have angular animation and we used to
have something called Blazer animate but
it's now part of Blazer eyes so we still
have that perhaps not as good I don't
know but it's still there
unit testing was one of the things that
I I was really
we've had that from from the start Eagle
Hansen here here made an awesome
framework for testing your blazing
components that doesn't spin up a a web
browser and all of that you can really
test it without it it's super easy and
super good and if you are what if you
didn't see Eagles uh session uh this
Wednesday right
and you should definitely check that out
because it was really great
rounding
foreign
we have that that's that's kind of a
base thing thing apparently you need to
add that to angler or something I don't
know
HTTP well they have that too
directives uh
we don't have that
I'm not entirely sure uh
what the benefits are perhaps you know
but
and the last one was pipes and as from
what I understand is it's like
formatting for formatting text and
things like that we kind of have that
in.net but not as
not as easy perhaps but we do have that
okay so one of the questions I get a lot
is should we write our code in the racer
file or in code behind so what are you
doing eraser file
code behind
it's about 50 50. okay
so when Blazer came out it was a lot of
things
the main
examples was to write in the race of
file
and
I sat off and I said you know what I'm
I don't like this I'm gonna go code
behind
because that's what I'm used to
separation separation of concerns and
all of that
and
then I said to myself if Microsoft says
we should use eraser files or they
didn't really do that but they well in
all their samples they they used racer
you know what I'm gonna try it I'm gonna
give I'm gonna give it a couple weeks
I'm gonna try
and the fact that I don't have to
context switch or or switch files and
and just work in the same file
some people say yeah but but having all
that code inside of it with their markup
then you should probably move that into
a service or something like that anyways
because you want it to be testable and
stuff like that but
I would encourage you those of you who
are running code behind try to run it in
in racer file because what happens is
that it's going to take the race of
files it's going to convert that to
c-sharp code it's going to take your
code behind mash them together and then
compile it so it's kind of not any
separations anyways so it's just a
mental separation in this case
so it boosted our productivity a lot
question I get
a lot
so hi Jimmy
um we are just about to start with
blazer what component Library should you
use
well file new
um I'm all for like trying out you need
to understand the components how they
work how to work with components before
you get into a
component Library
now having said that there are a lot of
vendors that invest time and money into
components we have progress Dev Express
syncfusion RADS and Blazer eyes matte
Blazer mud Blazer and the bottom one is
the grid that I did so that's open
source if you wanted to check that out
it might be a a good example to show
that to show how I mean a grid is
fairly Advanced control so you can see
how how you could build that from
scratch if you want to
now
building a
component library is not a good idea I
mean there's a lot of awesome people
doing this for a living
in our case we had
we had a couple of special things that
we needed we needed sorting well
that's kind of a given
we needed a sign highlighting so we
wanted
positive numbers wanted we we wanted
them to be blue and negative numbers
wanted to be wanted to be read for
example and instead of having that as a
special
column renderer or whatever it was
super easy for us to just highlight sine
equals true and we were done
we also had a different
um
we wanted people to use it on the the um
on the web on on a computer or I am a
tablet and we wanted people to be able
to use it on the phone
so we built in functionality to remove
columns so if the the size
um
if the size gets smaller we can remove
some columns and put them beneath I
haven't seen that in at least in a lot
of different vendors I'm sure they're
out there but that was one of the things
we needed but back then when we started
this there were none of those kinds of
functionalities but
you should you should make your own
components I'm not saying that you
should make your own grid but I'm saying
that everything you build should be in a
component
now in the um web form days and stuff
like that
building component libraries or
components was kind of tricky
but with blazer that's the kind of
things you need to think about because
everything is components
so think it think in a component-centric
way can this code be reused am I writing
the same code twice for some reason
and the real benefit is
to have the whole team do the same
things
so what we did was that we created our
own button
so I never understood why we should do
it and own but I mean it's kind of
simple to do that right
but
in this case this is this is using this
is just a HTML button it's using the BTN
and BTM primary this is from bootstrap
so we are saving a customer
is that a primary button or is it a a
success button
we were deleting a customer with doing
something dangerous is it dangerous is
is it not as dangerous to do that could
be used to primary it anyway
so instead of having like all these
things that we need to remember and or
the whole team needs to remember that
we created our own component so we're
basically saying that we're just happy
we have an enum
if it's a default button then it's going
to use the BTN primary
if it is a save button we're going to
use the BTM primary again
if it's cancel button it's a danger
button because canceling stuff is
dangerous
and if it's a delete button same thing
there
so by doing this kind of abstraction
we not only help ourselves because we
know that we're saving something we
don't need to remember if it's primary
danger success whatever
if you're changing from
from bootstrap
I'm gonna need to change this one
when we upgraded
um from bootstrap for something to five
there were some changes that happened
only one place to chase it
was saved a lot of time
so here comes my advice
components everywhere build components
build reusable components
try to um
build helper components like the one I
just showed you that doesn't add any
functionality but it adds an abstraction
layer that makes it easier to understand
and to follow
my boss came to me and he said okay I
know we just jumped on Blazer but is
this something that Microsoft is going
to abandon next week
and I'm like
I don't know
I hope not
but I mean they're investing real a lot
of time into that and you saw the list
of the component vendors and that's
probably just half the list
but I get that question a lot does
companies use Blazer
I would not be able to mention any
companies that are using angular react
because companies are not talking about
that
obviously the maintainers Google and
Twitter and stuff like that but
I would not be able to tell you if what
technology they're using
but I can't tell you this that big
Swedish companies I'm not allowed to say
what company
are using License Day in internally you
know using places server and we're
talking about the Swedish company that
you all have heard of that's the level
of Swedish company we're talking about
and I had a lot of friends working in a
consultant consultancy business and they
are using Blazer they have lots of
customers using Blazer
I did a workshop for a consultant's
agency and then they have like 10
different customers that are using
Blazer so yes people and companies are
using Blazer they're not talking about
it though
so let's compare the different
Technologies so I I've decided to
compare Blazer server with blazer web
assembly because these are the two web
Technologies it's kind of comparing
Blazer hybrid into this doesn't make
sense to me
so the first thing with blazer server is
that it has a fast startup
doesn't have anything to download it's
just a small JavaScript and you're
running it
you can use the full server capabilities
so that means that you can you can get
to databases you can get to the file
system or whatever you want to do
the browser support at least was a
little bit better with blazer server I'm
not sure actually how how what it is
with docket seven but it was a little
bit a little bit more versions had
support for that
your code is safe it's running on the
server you can't decompile it unless you
have access to the server
and this is a little bit controversial
perhaps but
I really like the fact that you can call
the database directly you don't need an
API or a web API I should say you should
definitely do it in API thing but not a
web API
so the bad things is that you need a
constant connection with signalr
I saw a demo from Steve Sanderson on on
Twitter I believe or YouTube it was on
YouTube where it showed some of the
things that are coming in.net 8 and some
of these things are actually
um
they have solutions for some of these
things
coming up
doesn't have an offline support because
of the first rule you need a constant
connection
it does have a little bit of higher
latency because it when you click a
button it goes back to the server the
server renders everything and push that
back to the client
we have never heard that Blazer is slow
because of Blazer we have had server
problems on slow databases and all of
that but never
for the reason that it's we're running
Blazer server
since everything is on the server we
have usage States we have um the
connections and all of that stuff and
they run the tree and everything it does
have a higher server low
and it requires asb.net on the server I
don't know if that's bad but it does
so for webassembly
you can definitely do a pwa which is
kind of nice
you can run it anywhere so you can run
it on GitHub Pages you can run it on
Azure web
Azure static web apps you can run it
from a file share which is kind of nice
you don't need to do any round trips to
the server
we have
ahead of time compilation which I
mentioned in the beginning so we have we
can speed things up it's
insanely fast
it does have a large footprint and we
will get back to that in a bit as well
you need an API you can can't do direct
database access and again it's
controversial you might like that you
might not like that but
your code is not safe
it's dotnet dlls they can be decompiled
quite easily but that's kind of the
thing that all JavaScript developers had
had for years so it's not a new thing
but if you're coming from MVC and
abrasive page of world you kind of need
to think about where are my logic can I
have it on the client is the secret in
any way
so let's talk a little bit more about
the server so I mentioned that the
server load goes up a little bit
so when it comes to memory consumption
what's happening is that it's saving all
the state on the server for all the
users that it's connected to the server
when let's say the database goes down
for for some kind of Reason what do the
people do then what do the users do well
let's start pressing F5
frantically ask me how I know
and what happens then is that the the
signal or connection is going to be
disconnected
it's going to reload the page you're
going to hook up another connection and
the old one is going to be there for by
default of three minutes taking up space
and then when they do that like
come on come on it's like
a million connections
right there
um
so the advice here is to add a refresh
button
now since the in our case the SQL server
was down it wouldn't help but don't let
your users press F5
try to add a refresh button with oh I'm
going to press that button it's going to
refresh and everything is is awesome
don't mix Blazer non-blazer Pages we did
that in the beginning so what happened
is that you can do the same logic you
have a a Blazer page or a Blazer
component which is routed through all
through Blazer
you move to an MBC page or a racer page
it's going to disconnect that and you're
going to reload the the site it's going
to disconnect the the connection and
when you move back it's going to connect
again so try not to mix different
Technologies even though it is possible
but you need to think about that a
little bit
now the really cool thing with blazer
was that we got a completely different
kind of feedback
because they said hey nothing is
happening I pressed the button and
things happening
we're like yeah you save the same thing
seven times that's what happened
because we didn't think about because
with MVC and racer Pages the whole page
reloaded they understood that something
happened when I pressed the button
but with blazer when I pressed the
button nothing happened because it
didn't reload the whole page it did
stuff but it didn't reload the whole
page
and so that was the first kind of
realization that oh this is kind of cool
this is an interactive website now
the second thing that happened was that
okay so I'm updating something in this
completely different system that we're
syncing into our database but this
completely different system why do I
have to up why do I need to update this
page
so our user kind of get used to
everything happening with with signalr
we we could push changes into the web
browser
and they were like we want this this is
what why do we have to really why do we
have to press the refresh button
and that kind of like blew my mind
because that change
was we're talking about weeks until they
kind of demanded that the UI should
update directly which is kind of cool
so the advice here is make sure you
notify the user tell the user that
something happened I I this post is
saved or whatever it may be
the development speed
using Blazer compared to in our case MVC
saved our project I would say
we were doing a very huge um
chains of the back office system and
there were other companies that were
doing the same change
we were six developers I think and they
had 10 more resources and we were done
before them
because we didn't context switch we
stayed in Blazer we were productive in
Blazer and in some cases it was even
faster to actually move the
functionality to Blazer rather than fix
the problem in MVC which is kind of cool
so one of the things that also hear is
is Blazer server slow well we talked
about that we touched on that subject
and we never got that feedback if you
have really bad connection that would
probably be be a problem but if we have
I mean
the connection here the connection in
Sweden it it works
now I got
um
I was at the conference in Sweden I was
talking to a couple guys that came up to
me and said so we're thinking about
doing places server police advices and
they had two things that they needed
they needed
it had to work offline
and it had to work with millions of
users
now these two things are the two things
the top two things that Blazer server
can't do or is really bad at at least
can't do offline and millions of users
is definitely gonna be a
lots of load on the server
so I explained well you should
definitely go with webassembly in that
case so Blazer service not for everyone
so what about webassembly
so let's talk about the specific things
footprint or the loading time
I am I went on on Facebook and I asked
so um what kind of questions would you
like to have answered and that was one
of the top questions
that the footprint all of these dlls
that needs to get downloaded that's like
one megabyte of of
of webassembly stuff right
so I thought you know what I want to
know what other sites do well is this
really a problem
so Facebook has 16 megabytes of
JavaScript
compared to the the
web assembly runtime which is around one
megabyte
16 that's 16 times more right
Pinterest has a little bit more than six
megabytes YouTube four megabytes Twitter
has a little bit more than three
megabytes stack over for 1.5
Apple's home page a little bit more than
one
and Blazer comes out the the Blazer demo
site I should say comes in
at 1.2 back then I think it's even lower
now
so when we're talking about the
footprint like oh it's one megabyte that
is not really a problem what is a
problem is a loading time because it
takes a little bit of time to spin
everything up
again ahead of time compilation will
help
so what can we do well we can add a
progress bar because as long as you're
telling your customers that something is
happening
it's fine
in the dotnet 7 template the new one
they added it added a progress bar for
us
so that's kind of we got that one
we can use server pre-render so we can
use Blazer server rendering everything
for us pushing that to the web browser
and then when webassembly is finished
loading it will just switch out
we can use Mr sakamoto's pre-render
which is taking our site when we are
publishing it
rendering everything
and then adds it to the webassembly so
it it's perfect for seos but it's not
good for um
for dynamic content
but that's an option or we can do ahead
of time compilation which is going to
load a whole it's footprint is bigger
the load time is smaller so
depending on where where you are I guess
so
we are in the UK
and I just have to show you one of my
projects that I've been working on
it's called Zed Xbox and there's a story
behind that I
when I was
seven years old my parents got me my
first computer
at ZX Spectrum
and one of the things that I I I thought
that this was super cool so I started
making a emulator
for the Xbox that's where the Xbox comes
from
and this has kind of become my hello
world so every new technology I
encounter I have a hololens one I have
um a Dartmouth micro framework one so
every new technology I encounter I kind
of can I implement it can I Implement my
C C sharp Spectrum emulator in that new
technology so I want to show you
spoilers I could
so here it is
so if you want to try it out and no you
can't see that
Let's uh let's actually do it like this
there we go
awesome
so I started off with a 48k and then the
128k and this is running a Blazer web
assembly
and it's running ahead of time compiled
so let's let's just reload the page and
see the time it takes boom
again everything is already downloaded
so the first download was what took a
little bit of time but this is the
experience when you go back to the site
the second time boom
pretty fast and this is not the the out
of the box
really really simple demo
so let's uh let's kick it off let's see
if we can do something
before I load magic minor I want to I
just want to say that so I
I did a lot of Windows Phone development
on Windows 8 development so I did a lot
of games for a company here in the UK
called um
ultimate
no
Elite sorry Elite
not ultimate ultimate is my favorite
company though
and I have yet to this day
never beaten the first level on manic
Miner
has anyone done that
no one
oh
one it's always one
I cannot for the life of me beat the
first level
let's kick it off let's see here
there we go and it does have sound I
have muted it because it's kind of
annoying
see if I can unmute it
can you hear it back
let's let's mute that and uh it's
obvious I can move around let's see if I
can figure out the keys here oh there we
go and I can move around
and jump and stuff
and die
one day
should beat this
all right let's jump back
there we go so do we have any questions
yes
so the question is uh what is the
approach when doing server pre-render
and then switch into webassembly it is
super simple uh
one one of the things that if you if you
just do it basically what you need to do
is you need to say that the first
you need to change the index HTML to
eraser page
when you add the tag for for the um
for the Blazer part of the site you need
to say server pre-rendered or something
like that
so just doing that will will basically
do what you need the problem is that
what what is going to happen is that
it's going to load the server side and
when the web assembly is done it's going
to do a request again and do load
everything again
but there is something called Preserve
oh I should know this uh preserved state
or something like that that will you can
just add that to the racer page and add
a little bit you need to rewrite the
code just a little bit
what happens is that it's going to take
the state of the component it's going to
render that in base64 on the page and
when webassembly starts up it's going to
take that state load that state and it's
not going to load the same data twice
so it's pretty straightforward but you
need to you need to change the code just
a little bit
customers
yes
sorry once again
every 30 seconds
is that
I would talk in Blazer server or Blazer
web suddenly
uh so the question is if we have lots of
rows in a in a grid and they're grouped
and we're going to update it uh in in a
fairly fast pace it's doable
well it's it's not less doable in in
with any other technology
when it comes to
pushing from the server
I would not recommend doing a lot of
push-up data because it takes resources
when it comes to webassembly we're
probably talking about pulling the
information more where you can Implement
signalr and do that but
um there are also
built-in functionality which is called
virtualize which is basically going to
take that grid and only render those
rows that are visible inside of of the
screen and render like a div above
underneath
above and beneath above and beneath
um so that you can so it looks correct
but it's only renders part of it but
absolutely it's it's possible it I I see
no no problem with that with the
technology in itself
yes
[Music]
so the question is is there coming
something that solves the problem with
with blazer server basically when we
push an update you will uh the
connection is going to get killed off
and well you're going to lose the state
not that I know of
um
it's really a problem
so there are two things happening so one
of the things that is that the user is
going to get kicked off and and you're
going to create a new session or a new
connection
the other thing is that you're going to
be down for
I think I've timed it to seven seconds
or something like that when we're we're
publishing something in production
but as far as I know you know
still still gonna need the connection
yes
so the problem is that when you push an
update to the application the
application would certainly need to be
reloaded anyway what you could do is you
could look into Technologies like
[Music]
for example so that the existing apps
that are active right now they keep
running until they use an alcohol and
then the next time they come in they
will go to the new version of that
so Eagle added for for the people at
home you can use app slots to um to
basically publish your new site and then
make your users switch over to the new
one
any other question yes
doing
I think there are some tree shaking in
in happening when you're when you're
compiling to iot but I'm I'm not
entirely uh
yes yes thank you
any other questions
if you have any more questions please
come up to me I have stickers
and so
just to summarize should we go all in
Blazer well I'm going to give you the
Microsoft answer it depends
it depends on on what you're doing that
your teams and stuff like that is it
production ready yes
should you invest time in it yes
will it replace angular reactive View
for some people yes
so please
and hit me up and talk to me if you want
to and I'll be happy to answer any
questions you may have thank you so much
[Applause]